Speaker 1: There's a really interesting kind
of shuffling, I guess we would call it, of
right wing media.
I'm not going to spend a ton of time on this
today.
And those of you who have been watching, listening
to recent episodes, you already know about
this.
It's not actually happening.
But there's a growing narrative that Fox News
has abandoned Donald Trump now.
The reality is much more measured.
It's not that Fox has abandoned Trump, and
it's not that Fox is completely brown nosing
Trump.
There's sort of a spectrum on Fox News, but
Fox News is doing the best possible thing
for their business with their news coverage
now.
The night time opinion people are still sucking
up to Trump as much as they ever were.
Even to some degree, the Fox and Friends people
are as well.
But Fox News is setting itself up to be able
to kind of pull the escape of the eject button
and go to someone else if indeed Trump is
not the Republican nominee in 2024, and maybe
there's even a slight preference for someone
else, but regardless, they're still staying.
Keeping options open.
Not wanting to lose access to Trump.
Newsmax is playing up the war between Trump
and Fox News, and of course they would.
It's to their advantage if you are targeting
the most aggressively sycophantic elements
of the Fox News audience, they are the hardcore
maggots.
And one of the things that might steer them
to your network is to convince them that Fox
News has abandoned your president or whatever.
And so they're really playing it up.
And they are mentioning at any opportunity
that it's been 100 days since Trump was on
fox news.
Speaker 2: And coming up, shadow banned.
Why former president trump hasn't appeared
on the major, major news network in over 100
days.
That's Fox News.
What's going on there?
We discuss after the break.
Speaker 1: That's a very explosive story for
Newsmax.
Why has it been 100 days since Trump appeared
on Fox News?
It's all self-serving and self-interested.
That's all it is.
Yes, Fox may have a slight preference for
someone else.
Yes, Fox wants to set itself up to have access
to whoever is the nominee in 2024 for the
Republicans.
But they're not actually turning on Trump
in any serious way.
Then they brought on some expert.
I don't even know who this guy is.
And again, the topic is about Trump and praising
Newsmax and it's the cover.
Newsmax is increasingly covering Trump not
being on Fox News, if not ahead.
Speaker 6: And so it would seem they would
want to track this and he could announce any
day now.
Now, there are some people who say he's not
going to do that to after midterms, but we
don't know that.
And it defies common logic.
How do you talk about the election for president
without talking about Donald Trump?
And you think they're not talking about him,
they're trying to avoid him?
I mean, he may appear sooner or later, but
they're still going to try their best to ignore
him.
Speaker 2: You know, it's interesting because
you mentioned.
Speaker 1: That this is interesting at the
bottom of the screen.
It says Murdoch's move away from Trump to
be more establishment, the idea being that
these are decisions being made not necessarily
by Rupert Murdoch personally, although maybe
he's involved, I believe I don't remember
which of Rupert Murdoch's kids there is like
Lachlan Murdoch and all these different I
don't I don't know which one of them is highly
involved at Fox News right now.
One of them is they're framing it as a personal
thing.
I think that this primarily continues to be
a business and access thing.
But but we'll learn more about that, I'm sure,
as we get beyond the midterms.
Speaker 2: Newsmax What you are so happy that
we do is, as I know many of our viewers are,
as I am as well, that we let our viewers decide.
I'm involved with the information and okay,
if you agree, great.
If you don't, you don't.
But even former President Trump has lauded
Newsmax.
Speaker 6: Certainly has and for good reason.
We give him then that vehicle to at least
speak to what he speaks to.
And again, let our viewers decide.
I mean, you know, we have an intelligent viewership,
as I thought, the Times and the posted, too.
Speaker 1: But now that's not true.
I would guess.
Speaker 6: We're finding out differently.
They are saying that The New York Times, of
all people, are the ones who come out and
say, you know what.
Speaker 3: This.
Speaker 5: Is what got me.
There is a there there.
Yeah, there's a there there.
Speaker 1: Brian Anderson Normally it's us
telling obvious lies, but every once in a
while, the New York Times will come out and
say something.
So that's what's going on.
Newsmax coverage is increasingly covering
Trump not being covered by Fox News in as
favorable terms as maybe they would like to
see.
And again, these are all business ploys.
Everybody wants to chalk this up.
And this is sometimes what I'll meet people
from outside the media space, like most people
I meet, are outside the media space, even
though because of the space I'm in, I know
a lot of media people as well.
The people in the media space get it.
But then I'll talk to people outside the media
space and they will understandably believe
all these narratives.
Fox News has taken this perspective for moral
reasons.
And then Newsmax has this other belief and
reaction would have yet to some degree, that
goes on.
But most of these networks and channels, it's
not like the David Pakman show where it's
just there's no posturing.
It's just my opinion.
That's it.
If there is a story I'm not interested in,
I just don't cover it.
If there's a story I'm interested in, I cover
it and I just give you my opinion.
There's no posturing.
It might be good for clicks or it might be
bad for clicks with Fox News and Newsmax and
whatever.
It's all being primarily analyzed through
the lens of what does this do for our viewership?
And Fox News right now has made the calculation
probably a correct one that they need to find
kind of straddle the fact that there is a
negative, there's a repelling going on by
some in the right wing of Trump.
And Trump might not be the nominee in 2024.
He might not even run.
And so they need to be ready for that to credibly
be able to rejoin the establishment, for lack
of a better term.
But they also need to keep the door open for
Trump.
That's their calculation.
It's nothing about ideology, although there
might be ideology, that's part of it.
Newsmax I guess they probably do love Trump,
but I'm sure there are people who work at
Newsmax who are kind of see Trump as a buffoon.
But their calculation is playing up.
The war between Trump and Fox News is good
for our viewership and it's good for our positioning,
and it might ingratiate us with Trump even
further so that he will appear on the network
more, talk about us more, etc..
That's what's going on.
Don't don't think it's anything else